i've been involved in epidemiology
research projects and i
i don't want it to seem like we're
saying oh
epidemiology is is weak science just let
that go in one ear and out the other it
serves a really important purpose and
all types of research do but what's
really important is that when we see the
headline you gotta unfortunately reward
them with the clicks yeah it sucks but
you gotta at least take a look and say
was this in a petri dish was it in a
mouse was it in a fruit fly was it in a
huge you know collection of surveys was
this a randomized controlled trial you
got to get an idea of what kind of
research it was that they're reacting to
and then you have to acknowledge the
shortcoming of every single type of
research
rcts included right so if it happened in
a petri dish or a flu a fruit fly or a
mouse immediately you have to say well
let's wait and see yeah you know someone
will follow up with more data yeah and
that's fine it's okay to take a wait and
see approach
something is an epidemiology finding you
say okay well that's interesting let's
see if this gets gets replicated
experimentally
someone comes out with a randomized
controlled trial and there's 12
participants per group
you say well that's an interesting
finding but
am i necessarily certain that those 12
people represent the global population
or the population that is most relevant
to me yeah probably not right so
whatever layer of research you're
looking at there's going to be
limitations even
the renowned meta analysis right so i
mentioned an analysis a meta-analysis
earlier where i said yeah the analysis
indicated 500 calories per day is a big
enough deficit to blunt your lean mass
gains but don't take it too literally
and the reason i say that is a
meta-analysis can only
calculate based on the data that exists
yeah and the data that exists are
dependent upon the conditions in which
they're collected
and so uh you might look for example
at a body of literature and find bias
that is built into the literature
and cannot be
untangled without more research right so
if you're looking at high versus low
protein intakes in a big meta regression
but you also notice most of the high
protein studies are specifically in
elderly folks and a lot of the other
studies are more likely to be in younger
folks now you've got age and protein
level kind of intermingled and you can't
parse those out without additional stuff
oh yeah you you actually see this all
the time in a type of meta-analysis that
i understand why it exists but i
personally don't like it
so there's a certain genre of
meta-analysis where they essentially
take
just all of the studies that have
reported on a particular outcome and
then
and it's not necessarily studies where
like one group does x one group does y
and then like compare between the two
groups those
those are my favorite type types of
metas but this type that i'm talking
about basically you just get all of the
studies that report on a particular
outcome and then you just look to see
kind of between studies
what study characteristics are
predictive of
better
or
of better results for the outcome of
interest um and so like in in one of
those that comes to mind
i think it was just looking at like what
resistance training variables are
associated with lean mass gains in
female lifters i think that's what it
was
but one of the things that they found
was that
the length of the training intervention
was negatively associated with lean mass
gains in other words if you interpreted
that literally the longer someone trains
not the the less not
basically like it's not saying the rate
of gains slows down over time it's
saying the absolute gains are smaller
with longer training intervention so you
know if you interpreted that literally
like hey i train for three months and
put on five kilos of muscle mass and
then over the next three years i lose
two kilos and and that's what i should
expect so over time i only gained three
kilos or or something like that um
but much like you're getting at
the the
the thing that was actually driving that
finding was that most of the really
long-term interventions were in elderly
subjects because
most of the studies in younger people is
it's college kids and so you're pretty
much limited by the length of a semester
and so those studies run
16 weeks if you're really on the ball
and you can get everyone in the lab on
day one typically you're limited to
about 12 weeks tops